bonjour à tous je suis alexandra en
effet il ya deux ans un peu comme ce
moment je j'étais bien et en même temps
avec une petite appréhension lisant ben
voilà qu'est ce que je veux de ma vie et
puis finalement se jeter se posait la
question de mois alexandra qu'est ce que
je suis qu'est ce que j'ai envie d'être
c'est quoi ma vie et qu'est ce que j'ai
envie d'offrir à ce monde la grande
question est pourquoi je me suis posé
cette question parce qu'en fait
finalement j'étais heureuse mais pas
tout le temps et puis j'avais envie de
plus j'avais l'impression de porter un
costume qui était pas forcément liens
dans ma vie à moi j'avais l'impression
d'être pas forcément très douce avec moi
j'avais l'impression de vivre une vie
qui exploitait pas forcément tout ce que
je pouvais offrir
j'avais des relations qui étaient très
agréables n'est pas profonde et je
faisais un boulot qui me plaisait mais
où je me disais mais je veux plus et je
veux quelque chose et je veux vraiment
être complètement mois et apporter ce
que je suis moi alexandra dans toute ma
vie donc c'était une réflexion globale
je me suis posé cette question et
finalement comment fait pour que se
décline dans la vraie vie parce que
finalement les questions de s'en poser
toute sa vie est resté dans sa tête à
dire et si et si et si et si je faisais
ça et si je faisais ça en fait une une
vie ça se cette vie vraiment et comment
on fait pour vivre sa vie comme on a
envie de la vie bah c'était la bonne
question déjà de se poser la question de
se dire ok moi qu'est ce que j'ai envie
de vivre au quotidien
qu'est ce qui est important pour moi
quelle relation j'ai envie d'avoir avec
les gens quand je me lève qu'est ce que
j'ai envie de faire dans quelle énergie
j'ai envie d'être
qu'est ce que j'ai envie d'apporter à ce
monde-là
et moi j'avais vraiment envie de faire
partie du monde de demain un monde où
que j'imagine plus tourner sur l'humain
où on aurait des relations plus saines
les uns avec les autres avec du respect
avec dont ça passe je pense par un
respect par son enfin avec soin et puis
ensuite avec les autres ouais qu'est ce
que j'ai envie de faire de ma vie qu'est
ce que j'ai envie de donner en fait
c'était ça la question et j'ai commencé
à écrire ce que j'avais envie de faire
ce qui m'attirait - alexandra parce que
je pensais que la société avait envie
que je sois pas ce que je pensais que
mais peut-être ma famille mes parents
avaient envie que je sois mais moi ce
qui me faisait vibrer ce qui me faisait
vie
et ce pour quoi en fait j'étais là et
donc j'ai commencé à écrire ce que
j'avais envie de vivre et j'étais un
petit peu conceptuel
c'était plus de l'ordre du ressenti que
concrètement comment ça se matérialise
mais il y avait quelque chose qui était
assez fort c'est que j'avais envie
d'aller rencontrer des gens qui
croyaient au même chose que moi et donc
bah je suis allé rencontrer des gens je
suis allé rencontrer des gens donc moi
je faisais du conseil avant et en
conduite du changement et je suis allé
rencontrer des gens qui travaillaient
sur la thématique de mettre l'humain au
centre
que ce soit dans le conseil ou sinon de
développer les capacités de l'être
humain pour aller vers plus de soin et
j'ai rencontré des gens et je suis allé
à des conférences et
et j'ai lu des bouquins sur le
développement personnel sur comment on
arrive à mieux vivre sa vie finalement
et à se libérer et à aller vers ce qu'on
est vraiment et de ça finalement j'ai
envie de partager
donc j'ai commencé à faire une première
expérience des rencontres qui se sont en
fait traduit par un blog je me suis dit
ben voila j'ai vécu tout ça j'ai vu tous
âges et j'assiste à ces conférences
j'ai envie de partager ce que je suis en
train de vivre donc j'ai commencé parce
que j'en avais envie à écrire sur les
autres et puis de toutes ces rencontres
j'ai rencontré une association qui
s'appelle api lab et qu'un laboratoire
du bonheur et qui a pour objectif de
faire monter la france sur le podium des
pays les plus heureux au monde
et là je me suis dit cool c'est chouette
c'est chouette cet assaut ça me parle je
crois que c'est ce que j'ai envie de
faire mais en fait de ma vie donc je
suis allé dans cette association
j'ai travaillé avec les entreprises pour
finalement se dire ouais d'accord on
travaille mais si on travaillait d'une
autre manière en prenant pas forcément
l'être humain comme quelque chose qu'on
va pressurisés et qu'on va exploiter
mais si l'individu était valorisé et mis
en avant et et si l'individu était
heureux et épanoui et qu'on utilisait le
plus beau de ce qui peut offrir pour
finalement faire que l'ensemble du
système soit plus heureux ça c'était la
question sur laquelle de travailler au
sein de l'association api nam et puis je
me suis rendu compte que que j'aimais
beaucoup cette association que c'était
c'était chouette mais j'avais envie
d'encore plus est en fait de me limiter
encore - enfin c'est à dire d'enlever
ses limites et ses barrières et de me
dire ok ça c'est une première étape
j'ai fait ça je
j'ai eu une page facebook où je
commençais à finalement partager tout ce
que je pouvais rencontrer ont rencontré
grâce à cette association et ça m'a
ouvert l'esprit sur ce qui se faisait
dans le monde et je me suis dit mais en
fait là je suis encore en train
d'emprunter un costume qui est super
chouette parce qu'en fait il est il est
plus sympa que celui d'avant quand
j'étais dans le conseil ou quand ils ne
correspondent plus ça me parle plus mais
en fait c'est encore pas mon costume et
je me suis dit ben moi ma vie prendre ma
vie en main c'est aussi offrir encore
plus de ce que je suis et donc j'ai
quitté cette association pour me dire
bah voilà là je sens que je suis prête à
offrir davantage encore ça ça a été
possible parce que j'ai décidé il ya un
an
faire un travail sur moi accompagné d'un
coach en disant voilà j'ai fait beaucoup
de choses j'apprends énormément aimé là
j'ai besoin de mettre un coup
d'accélérateur de mettre un coup
d'accélérateur pour me débarrasser de
choses que finalement j'avais très mal
et dans mon sac à dos et dont j'avais
plus besoin n'était pas forcément facile
de le faire tout seul parce que ben
voilà on est le problème et la solution
est que quand on est accompagnée bien il
ya des choses qui viennent plus
rapidement et voilà j'avais besoin de ça
de me débarrasser de me délester de
certaines choses pour aller encore vers
plus de moi et ça m'a permis finalement
de me positionner à ma manière
j'avais pas envie de me définir dans un
métier j'avais pas envie de rentrer dans
une case parce qu'en fait j'ai juste
envie d'être moi et c'est bizarre c'est
pas forcément ce à quoi on est préparé
et puis ça veut dire quoi être moi
finalement j'ai l'impression de vivre un
peu ma vie comme une exploratrice et
c'est ce que je mets sur ma carte de
visite parce que j'ai une carte de
visite il en faut bien une quand je
rencontre des gens et en fait moi ce qui
me fait vraiment kiffé dans ma vie c'est
de rencontrer les jambes c'est
d'apprendre des gens c'est d'évoluer de
grandir
et puis finalement que toutes ces
rencontres modifie ce que je suis et que
je puisse partager ce un plus grand
nombre en disant ben ouais finalement
devenir soit bien qu'on ait une
éducation
bien qu'on ait eu des études n'a que la
société nous dit
comment il faut vivre finalement être
soi c'est possible c'est possible et je
pense sincèrement que ce ça être soi
c'est ce dont le monde a besoin
aujourd'hui parce qu'on arrive à la fin
d'un système et la création d'un nouveau
et je pense sincèrement que aller vers
plus de soi c'est ce qui permettra
demain de de faire quelque chose d'autre
de ce monde
en tout cas c'est ma conception de la
vie et ça sera juste la mienne et c'est
ce que j'ai envie de faire partager et
je suis aujourd'hui ici par les
différentes expériences que je vous ai
raconté
c'est à dire j'ai commencé par mon blog
ensuite j'ai fait ma page facebook
ensuite je me suis dit ben voilà de
cette envie de partage mois j'assiste à
plein de conférence j'insiste je fais
des des interventions jeux jeux furent
est un peu partout et il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas forcément le temps de faire
une veille sur les événements qui ont
lieu alors moi j'habite à paris qui ont
lu à paris donc je me suis dit je vais
faire une newsletter pour informer des
gens des différents évènements qui peut
se passer à paris c'était une envie de
partage et dans cette newsletter
finalement j'ai commencé à écrire des
textes j'ai commencé un peu à raconter
ma vie ce que j'étais en train de faire
où j'en étais et j'ai mis une personne
dans cette dans cette newsletter qui
finalement m'a proposé il ya deux mois
d'être ici pour venir témoigner donc si
je vous partage cette information c'est
que pour vous dire que finalement quand
on fonctionne par envie parce qu'on
croit
bon pour soi et qu'on se dit juste voilà
je fais ces choses là parce que j'en ai
envie c'est moi et voilà je peux juste
pas faire autrement
finalement il arrive des choses
incroyables parce que un ted ben j'avais
ça dans l'esprit mais je m'étais jamais
dit ben finalement je vais en faire un
tout de suite maintenant
et puis finalement quand on pose les
différentes choses qu'on a envie de
vivre
il ya des choses qui arrivent comme ça
et je trouve ça assez incroyable et pour
vous dire aussi ce que je fais donc plus
largement mme on partage donc c'est des
témoignages une newsletter un blog
j'accompagne en fait les gens aussi dans
leur réflexion parce que moi je suis
passé par là et je vois que finalement
c'est pas c'est pas évident de se poser
cette question là parce qu'on nous l'a
jamais vraiment posé
qu'est ce qu'on veut vraiment faire
qu'est ce qu'on veut vraiment être égal
ce qu'on veut vraiment vivre moi c'est
cette question là que je me pose tous
les jours et tous les jours ça change un
peu parce que je rencontre de nouvelles
personnes parce que j'ose beaucoup plus
de choses et du coup voilà c'est il n'y
a rien qui est constant
tout évolue la vie n'est pas figé et je
voulais vous partager mes apprentissages
de sept de ses deux ans au début c'était
pas évident de
deux lancers donc moi je j'étais dans un
cabinet conseil pour moi c'était vital
de faire cet arrêt sur image et de se
dire qu'est ce que j'ai vraiment envie
de vivre dans ma vie et pour plein
c'était la catastrophe parce que c'était
la crise parce que mais qu'est ce que
j'allais faire vraiment mais je pars
sans avoir de boulot mais qu'est ce que
tu qu'est ce que tu vas faire enfin
c'était la panique pour beaucoup de gens
y compris moi parce qu'en fait j'avais
pas vraiment où j'allais et en même
temps j'ai accepté ça parce que c'est
aussi quand on laisse la place qu'on
peut se poser vraiment des questions et
donc j'ai pris le temps de me les poser
et de trouver des réponses et de faire
et de faire et quand je faisais
d'apprendre parce que ce que j'ai appris
aussi
finalement c'est que l'échec ça existe
pas vraiment c'est que des expériences
c'est la manière dont on envisage en
fait ce qu'on a fait alors on nous dit
jamais vraiment bazille essaye jette toi
tu verras bien j'ai l'impression qu'en
france c'est pas très commun et en même
temps grandit tellement quand on fait
les choses et que on fait les choses et
puis on apprend et puis on apprend ce
qu'on aime
on apprend ce qu'on n'aime pas et c'est
la manière aussi dont on se servent ces
expériences là est de se dire ok ben
j'ai fait ça peut-être que je me suis
planté comme j'estime que je me suis
planté mais finalement qu'est ce que
j'en fais qu'est ce que j'apprends et
voilà pendant ces deux ans
finalement jeu jallet un petit peu pas
au petit bonheur la chance parce que
justement c'était de plus en plus clair
là où j'avais envie d'aller
mais accepter de se tromper accepté de
finalement pas savoir accepter
d'essayer une fois deux fois et puis et
puis se planter et puis dire bon ok
d'accord c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
qu'est-ce que j'en fais en fait c'est
très formateur et est en fait je suis
prête aujourd'hui à accepter de
finalement d'être vulnérable d'être way
de pas savoir de pouvoir noteront p
avant j'étais pas du tout capable je
croyais qu'il fallait que je sois forte
je croyais qu'il fallait que je sois
toujours bien et maintenant de plus en
plus j'apprends je crois être un être
humain sans nous l'apprend pas l'école
c'est dommage donc de tous à prendre sa
vie en main
c'est finalement faire des choix faire
des choix
parce qu'en fait on n'est ni un peu dans
un véhicule et on sait pas trop comment
conduire mais il va falloir prendre des
directions ce genre de vie de prendre sa
vie en main ça permet de n'être plus
libres d'être plus qu'on a envie d'être
ce que je pourrais dire c'est que
s'entourer de personnes qui croient en
vous qui ne disent pas que vous êtes
complètement taré à faire ça mais plutôt
à se dire bah ouais c'est ces courageux
et évasif je crois en toi c'est ça aide
il ya plein de gens qui ont peur j'ai eu
peur très longtemps de plein de choses
mais en fait ben un moment donné j'avais
plus envie que la peur soit finalement m
de ma vie j'avais envie de plus et
d'aller au delà de ma peur donc j'ai
plus ou moins je sais pas si vous
connaissez cette phrase soyez le
changement vous voulez
voire dans le monde de gandhi alors je
la comprenais pas trop cette phrase
d'avant je me suis rendu compte que
finalement si on a envie de changer le
monde à sa manière
ça passe d'abord par soi et ensuite
c'est un effet boule de neige
donc voici mon histoire est en fait il
ya autant d'histoires que deux personnes
vous ai juste partager la mienne je
pense que vous auriez tous des choses à
raconter par rapport à ça moi je vous
poserai juste la question de qu'est ce
que vous avez envie d'être dans ce monde
là voilà merci à tous